[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden pidió al congreso que endurezca
las sanciones y controles a ejecutivos
bancarios que han quebrado para que
quede claro que nadie está por encima de
la ley la solicitud del mandatario se
produce en medio de la incertidumbre que
rodea el sistema financiero ampliamos
desde Washington
el tribunal supremo venezolano anuló un
artículo del Código de Justicia militar
que penalizaba la homosexualidad dentro
de las fuerzas armadas la corte señaló
que la normativa no era compatible con
la Constitución ni con leyes
internacionales
la confederación nacional de indígenas
de Ecuador apoyó el pedido de juicio
político que activó la oposición contra
el presidente Guillermo lasso a quien
acusan de corrupción y malversación de
fondos los indígenas pidieron que el
lazo sea apartado del cargo de inmediato
ampliamos desde quito
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos porque el presidente Joe
biden pidió al congreso que endurezca
sanciones y controles contra los
ejecutivos bancarios a quienes se les
compruebe que su mala gestión llevó a
quiebras o colaboró con la inestabilidad
que enfrenta actualmente el sistema
financiero estadounidense previamente
conversamos con Cristóbal Vázquez
corresponsal de France 24 en Washington
quien nos dijo puntualmente que le
solicitabaiden al congreso en medio de
esta alerta en la que se encuentra el
sistema financiero
solicitó al congreso que apruebe una
legislación que otorgue a los
reguladores financieros nuevos y amplios
poderes para recuperar las ganancias
obtenidas ilícitamente de los ejecutivos
de los bancos que entraron en bancarrota
la semana pasada imponer multas por
quiebras a los altos ejecutivos de estos
bancos además Busca también que estos
ejecutivos no puedan aceptar otros
trabajos en la industria financiera las
medidas contenidas en el plan de biden
se basarían en los poderes regulatorios
existentes que posee la corporación
Federal de seguros de depósitos de
Estados Unidos además se da en respuesta
a informes de que el director ejecutivo
de silicon Valley Bank vendió tres mil
millones de dólares en acciones del
banco poco antes de que los reguladores
federales se hicieran cargo de este
banco las propuestas enfrentan un futuro
incierto en el congreso sin embargo
porque los republicanos controlan la
cámara de representantes y se han
opuesto ya a iniciativas de biden para
fortalecer la regulaciones federales
Crisol también nos amplió sobre que
otros bancos están en riesgo de entrar
en una crisis de confianza teniendo en
cuenta que hay otras instituciones que
tienen grandes cantidades de depósitos
no asegurados
también de California fue uno de los
bancos que fue salvado esta semana sin
embargo Esta vez fue por once bancos de
los más grandes en Estados Unidos que
decidieron depositar 30 mil millones de
dólares al banco regional para tratar de
salvarlo y evitar los efectos
colaterales que su caída pudiera tener
en el sistema financiero estadounidense
la decisión vino después de que los
depositantes de este banco retiraran su
dinero de forma masiva y que la acción
de Republic cayera hasta 60% la bolsa de
valores de Nueva York hasta el punto de
que se suspense se suspendieran
momentáneamente sus operaciones en bolsa
otro de los bancos que están en la
cuerda floja es Credit suiza que tuvo
que pedir apoyo al central suizo para
evitar su caída retiro precipitado de
los fondos de los depositantes y el poco
encaje bancario de muchos otros bancos
medianos en Estados Unidos ha hecho que
la reserva Federal haya prestado cerca
de 160 mil millones de dólares en una
semana el nivel más alto en la historia
de préstamos en descuento que haya dado
la reserva Federal por su parte los a
grandes bancos como Banco América están
recibiendo cantidad de récord de
liquidez de nuevos clientes que buscan
seguridad en estas grandes instituciones
financieras
el canal de YouTube del expresidente
estadounidense Donald Trump fue
reactivado este viernes por lo que el
precandidato republicano podrá volver a
subir contenido la plataforma anunció
que tras una cuidadosa evaluación
determinaron que es parte del equilibrio
que los votantes escuchen por igual a
los a los principales candidatos previo
a las elecciones de 2024 en Estados
Unidos la cuenta del ex jefe de estado
quedó vetada tras el asalto al Capitolio
de 2021
y en el estado estadounidense de
California las tormentas invernales han
causado daños por valor de cientos de
millones de dólares al arrasar
comunidades derribar redes eléctricas y
provocar deslizamientos de tierra al
menos 20 personas han perdido la vida y
miles han tenido que abandonar sus
hogares por culpa de las graves
inundaciones la situación fuera de la
ciudad es también es preocupante con la
destrucción de hectáreas de cultivos por
el agua le avión tiene los detalles
esta zona agrícola del centro de
California Está irreconocible aquí el
desbordamiento de los ríos está ahogando
a cultivos de Almendros pistachos y
trigo los agricultores temen que el daño
tenga un efecto dominó en el suministro
de alimentos más allá del área local
entre yo y mis vecinos e incluso hacia
el oeste tienes miles y miles hectáreas
inundadas ha sido de esta manera durante
días y todos estos cultivos
Probablemente van a ser 100% destruidos
una vez que lleguen las próximas
tormentas los flujos se duplicarán se
triplicarán de nuevo Y seguirán llegando
seguirán llegando
las lluvias torrenciales no sólo
representan un peligro para las cosechas
en San Clemente como en otras partes del
Estado la tierra se deslizó y los
residentes evacuados van a tener que
esperar antes de poder volver a sus
hogares
creo que todo el mundo debe entender que
tenemos una situación dinámica aquí
tenemos otra tormenta en camino el suelo
sigue moviéndose Así que estas
estructuras siguen en peligro y desde la
perspectiva de la ciudad una vez más es
la seguridad ante todo vamos a
asegurarnos de que todo está listo antes
de obtener el visto bueno para que la
gente vuelva
según el servicio meteorológico nacional
Fuertes lluvias podrían golpear de nuevo
el Sur de California a principios de la
próxima semana
pasamos a Venezuela ya que el tribunal
supremo anuló un polémico artículo del
Código de Justicia militar que
penalizaba la homosexualidad dentro de
las fuerzas armadas una falta que podía
recibir una pena de hasta tres años de
prisión la sala constitucional del
máximo tribunal señaló que la Norma
establecida que estipulaba la condena el
militar que cometiera actos sexuales
contra Natura no resulta compatible con
la Carta Magna ni con instrumentos
internacionales la decisión del tribunal
es considerada como una victoria por
miembros del movimiento lgtbi más en
Venezuela primeramente estamos muy
felices de esta Victoria que obtuvo el
movimiento lgt en Venezuela
logramos La abolición de la
criminalización de la homosexualidad
llevamos muchísimos años luchando para
que se despenalizara y se aboliera esta
criminalización luego de que la
oposición ecuatoriana activara el
mecanismo de juicio político contra el
presidente Guillermo lasso la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas pidió la inmediata salida del
mandatario la oposición acusa al jefe de
estado de presunta corrupción y
malversación de fondos Mientras que el
gobierno calificó el pedido de un
atentado contra la democracia y un nuevo
intento desestabilización Desde aquí te
gustaba Ortega corresponsal de France 24
nos dio más detalles
la confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas de Ecuador exige la salida del
Poder del presidente Guillermo lasso De
igual forma ha dicho que se auto
convocarán ante la Corte constitucional
para exigir a esta que admita el proceso
de juicio político de la asamblea
nacional una vez que la asamblea
nacional presente el pedido ante este
órgano máximo de la constitución en
Ecuador De igual forma ha dicho que se
auto convocarán en movilizaciones y
plantones para esperar así a que esta se
pronuncie y exigir así y presentar su
exposición ante el pueblo ecuatoriano
sucede cuando la asamblea nacional
intenta enjuiciar al presidente de la
república Guillermo lasso por crímenes
de corrupción De igual forma han dicho
los parlamentarios que han conseguido
los votos para intentar enjuiciar al
presidente de la república y Guillermo
lasso las declaraciones que produce
también el presidente de la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas de Ecuador leónidas Isa sucede
en un momento tenso en el país andino
donde también han dicho que vuelven a
los reclamos de los primeros diez puntos
que originaron este país Las
movilizaciones del año de 2019 De igual
forma también ha dicho que con Irán
movilizándose para analizar así lo que
sucede en el país las declaraciones
suceden también cuando las
organizaciones sociales y la
confederación de Nacionales indígenas se
convocaron en una asamblea nacional para
evaluar así lo que sucede en este país
este 17 de marzo se conmemoró el día de
San Patricio patrón de Irlanda
precisamente por la gran herencia
irlandesa en Estados Unidos la
festividad se celebra a lo grande en
varias ciudades del país en Chicago el
río se volvió a pintar de verde y en
Nueva York el tradicional desfile volvió
a llenar las calles de Manhattan una
tradición que se celebra desde 1762 el
alcalde de la gran manzana destacó las
raíces irlandesas de su apellido Adams y
recordó que la ciudad fue levantada
entre otros por miles de inmigrantes
irlandeses
[Música]
así llegamos al final de este
Informativo en France 24 quédense con
nosotros que volvemos en breve
[Música]